As a young stand-up comedian, Adam Sandler
probably didn't foresee himself becoming one
of the most successful funnymen in Hollywood,
complete with a sweet Netflix deal, but he
did. While his movies are often beaten up
on by critics, the actor has starred in some
pretty classic comedies, like Happy Gilmore,
Billy Madison, and The Wedding Singer.
"Son of a b---- ball why didn't you just go
home."
However, if you look long enough at the man's
movies, you'll spot numerous in-jokes and
all sorts of references scattered throughout
his filmography.
The Star Wars connection
There's no denying Sandler's films have a
pretty strong connection to Star Wars.
"Millennium Falcon, Millennium Falcon. Cruising
along here. Whooo, almost hit a star."
Take Carrie Fisher, for example. The late
great actress is best remembered for her role
as Princess Leia, but did you know she also
worked on The Wedding Singer? As it turns
out, Fisher was an uncredited writer on the
1998 comedy, and according to Drew Barrymore,
Fisher was brought in to "write the girl's
part to make it balanced."
But the connections don't stop there. In 2012's
That's My Boy, Sandler plays Donny Berger,
a deadbeat dad who names his kid "Han Solo."
"You were basically the worst parent ever."
"I was awesome!"
Sandler's loyalty to this galaxy far, far
away might stem from a real-life interaction
he had with Han. According to Sandler, Harrison
Ford once asked him to wash his car as a way
to surprise his kids, as they were big Sandler
fans.
"He goes, my kids think you're funny. And
it would just be such a kick for them to see
that. And I was like, 'Uh, OK.'"
And if the galaxy's greatest space scoundrel
asks you for a favor, how can you say no?
The Godfather connection
Adam Sandler's extended movie universe doesn't
stop at Star Wars. The actor is also a big
fan of The Godfather, and a few of his films
contain references to Francis Ford Coppola's
classic gangster series. For proof, look no
further than Jack and Jill, which stars Michael
Corleone himself. The actor even references
the infamous scene from The Godfather Part
II where he threatens Diane Keaton with all
his power, asking her, "Don't you know me?"
Of course, in Jack and Jill, Pacino uses the
monologue to intimidate Sandler into getting
him a date with his twin sister.
And in Billy Madison, Sandler did his own
Michael Corleone impersonation, spoofing the
scene from The Godfather Part II where Michael
gives Fredo the kiss of death.
A Vendetta for V
Everybody has a type, and it seems like Adam
Sandler has a thing for women whose names
start with "V." Or against them, maybe? In
Billy Madison, Bridgette Wilson plays Veronica
Vaughn, a third-grade teacher who has strange
ways of motivating Billy to take his education
more seriously. Then, in Happy Gilmore, Sandler's
character is encouraged to get his head in
the golfing game by a PR executive named Virginia
Venit.
And in The Waterboy, Bobby Boucher falls in
love with witchy astrologer Vicki Vallencourt
, despite his mama's warnings.
"That woman is the devil, and I want you to
stay away from her, you hear me?"
"Yes, Mama."
"Now you come on inside, before that lil'
ol' witch cast a spell on ya!"
Big Daddy also saw its title slacker dumped
by his girlfriend Vanessa, and in Little Nicky,
Sandler's son of Satan falls head over heels
for Valerie Veran, a woman who helps Nicky
defeat his evil brothers.
And now we're wondering if maybe Adam Sandler
was the guy behind that Guy Fawkes mask…
The Tarantino connection
While The Ridiculous 6 didn't fare particularly
well with critics, there's no denying the
title is an intentional nod to Quentin Tarantino's
The Hateful Eight, which came out the same
year. But believe it or not, Adam Sandler
almost had the opportunity to work with Tarantino
himself, as the director originally wanted
the comedian to play the bat-wielding "Bear
Jew" in Inglourious Basterds.
Of course, the role eventually went to Eli
Roth, as Sandler chose to star in Funny People,
instead. But while Sandler missed out on a
great role, Sandler's pal Jonathan Loughran
managed to catch the Tarantino train. Loughran
has shown up in quite a few Sandler films,
but he's also taken serious roles with Tarantino,
like playing Jasper the mechanic in Death
Proof. He also appeared in Kill Bill as a
gross trucker, so perhaps it's not a coincidence
that when Loughran popped up in Sandler's
Sandy Wexler, he was playing a character by
the name of Trucker Jon.
The cat connection
There's a feline theme running through a lot
of Adam Sandler's movies, too. Anger Management,
for example, was a film where Sandler's character
designs clothing for his overweight pet, Meatball.
(Interestingly, that's the name of Sandler's
real-life dog, who served as the ring bearer
at Sandler's wedding.) Then there's Mr. Deeds,
where Sandler is slandered by a dishonest
reporter after he tried to save some cats
from a fire by tossing them out of a window.
In Don't Mess with the Zohan, Sandler's character
actually plays hacky sack with some poor cat,
and in Funny People, Sandler lets loose with
a few laughs as he watches a kid perform "Memory"
from, you guessed it, Cats. But hey, we're
not done with the feline jokes just yet. In
I Now Pronounce You Chuck and Larry, Chuck
falls for Alex when she's dressed up as a
Cat woman for Halloween. Meow there's a thread
worth tugging at.
His love-hate relationship with felines probably
has a little something to do with that time
he was mauled by a cheetah during an African
safari, but who knows.
Thanks for watching! Click the Looper icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel. Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love, too!